I know that you've heard me say many
times or you've read or listened on the
tapes that loving yourself is the most
powerful thing we can do and everything
flows everything flows beautifully I'm
not talking about vanity or arrogance
because that is not love that's always
fear I'm talking about just really
respecting and appreciating this
incredible magnificent being that we are
you know little babies know how to love
themselves you were born in pure love
all of you there's not one little baby
alive I that I know of that ever
criticizes its body or ever says my hips
are too big have you ever heard a baby
say that they're just thrilled and
delighted that they have a body they
rejoice in it and they love themselves
they love their toes they love
everything about themselves they
absolutely Express their feelings you
know and a baby is happy you know it
when a baby is angry the whole
neighborhood knows it they're never
scared to let people know how they feel
they live in the moment and they're
filled with courage and they're
wonderful and we were all like that got
to remember that you were filled with
courage and you were full of love and
you adored yourself when you were very
little need motivation watch your top
ten with with leave Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Louise Hay and my take on
her top 50 rules for success enjoy
I think that everything you think and
everything you speak goes out from you
into the universe and comes back to you
multiplied it's almost as though the
universe is listening to everything you
say and everything you think and saying
oh that's what they want but most of the
time we are talking very negatively
about ourselves we talk about how awful
we are we're not good enough we can't
get this we can't get that how can the
universe bring you anything good if
that's the way you're talking now you're
saying there's a quality of life doesn't
mean a really nice house or a really
nice it can but it doesn't have to but
what good is a nice car if you are full
of resentment all the time and you drive
around hating everybody that's not going
to help anything it's much better if you
had an old car and you were grateful and
appreciative of Life there is a law of
thinking and we are beginning to learn
about it and it is like a computer if
you have this gorgeous computer put in
front of you and you don't know what to
do with it it's a piece of junk but if
you learn the language of the computer
miracles happen
and that is what the law of thinking is
when you learn how it works miracles
happen
what you think
and what you believe it's what will come
true for you your thoughts create your
life
it's that simple and when we can get
that we can make enormous changes also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there one of the things that I think
about
the work that I do in the work our
company does is that every product that
we sell or the public that you get as a
gift from us uh has the possibility to
change the quality of your life to
improve the quality of your life now
whether you actually take that
opportunity or not is up to you that's
freedom but you have everything we give
out can help people really improve the
quality of their lives and that feels
good when we have a problem most of us
go oh panic panic God what are we going
to do
but I have something that I try to get
people to say when the minute there's a
problem you stop and you go all is well
all is well everything's working out for
my highest good and out of this
experience only good will come and I am
safe
and you do this if it's a small thing I
say it two or three times if it's a
bigger issue I Babble it incessantly but
all is well everything is working out
for my highest good out of this
situation only good will come and I am
safe now this gives this quiets your
inner turmoil down long enough for the
universe to find the solution to the
so-called problem see when there's
problems we don't have to fix problems
so much we need to fix our thinking
and our attitude about how we respond to
them
and then you get less and less and when
when the solution comes you say thank
you you start by doing what we call
doing affirmations and that is making
positive statements about your life that
are positive
and you do them deliberately you might
do them in the morning you might do them
at noon you might do them at night you
might do them you know twice a day or
whatever but you do this and you let
this become a habit and as you start to
do them things will begin to change
maybe on a very small level I call it
getting the green lights from the
parking places I mean they're not huge
things in your life they can be very
nice when you get three green lights in
a row and you're in a hurry
doing an affirmation is either writing
it down writing it on the wall or the
mirror or using a you know just saying
it what I like people to do is to stand
in front of a mirror and do their
affirmations because there's something
very powerful about looking in your own
eyes
and getting and accepting yourself or
noticing that you reject yourself when
you're saying something positive about
yourself so that would be a very
beginning way to start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror and this is
a big one and it's hard for lots of
people but you look in the mirror and I
say and say I love you I really really
love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them but if you can start your day
saying that it's very powerful we do
have a tendency in in the society to
just want to be fixed right to happen
and that's it when I get over this
problem this will be it I'll never have
to deal with anything well you know a
lot of us just want to stop when we hit
a safe place yeah I mean you've got a
bit of money you've got some nice
friends you have the good house to live
and you're okay you know and you think
all right that's fine I'm not going to
touch anything else but I have watched
me and how life works for me is that
when I get to a really good level then
it's like okay now we're going to deal
with this thing yeah yeah and there's
another thing and I've learned to just
say okay what do I do yeah yeah you know
instead of leave me alone don't talk to
me about that yeah I say thank you many
many many times of the day often not to
anyone else I just you know oh thank you
that's so wonderful thank you and it's
uh you know you find more and more
things to be thankful about we were I
was driving up today from San Diego and
the wildflowers on the hillsides are
just beautiful this year and I was
thinking I was so glad that I had the
opportunity to see them
because if I stayed down there I
wouldn't have but this drive which was
you know not a drive I particularly
wanted to make but it was gorgeous if
you
have very strong beliefs within you that
you don't deserve good things in your
life and a lot of people have that then
there can be delays
and sometimes people say well
affirmations don't work I've done them
but when they're doing for instance
Prosperity affirmations and they've done
some Prosperity affirmations and they
say it doesn't work nothing's happening
and I say well all right how many
Prosperity affirmations did you do in a
day and they'll say three probably and
they say all right how many poverty
affirmations did you do this day
and that could be 300 depending on where
you're coming from and what are is
running through your mind
see I have this one of my thoughts about
life is that only good lies before me
and I've been saying this for many years
so it doesn't really matter to me what
happens in life because I know it's
going to be good the simple part that
most people don't understand is that
every thought we think in every word we
speak is creating our future
it's as though our thoughts go out into
the universe and are accepted and
brought back to us as experience now
that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought and
every time you speak a word you are
literally painting your future making
your dinner whatever you want to call it
you are creating
and you're creating your own life
this is simple
but it's not easy
to accept but once you accept it then
you can start deliberately creating what
you want in your life
and you begin to be aware
of what you don't want in your life and
how you are contributing to it
now I think this has been around forever
but for some reason in the last 20 years
the universe has wanted this to go out
among all the people or all the people
that are ready for it
see most of us just think think think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do to
begin to train yourself to be aware of
what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am I
thinking
would I like this thought to create my
life
would I like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we could begin on the smallest level
to be aware of our thinking we can start
to make changes a lot of people say I
don't want to look at the past my
childhood was miserable and I never want
to think about it again well then it's
very important that you start forgiving
because forgiveness sort of wipes the
Slate clear so that other things can
come in yeah yeah well the tapping setup
phrase right is even though I have
whatever the problem is I love and
forgive myself
or I love and approve of myself yes
that's to me like the mirror work that I
do will have people do it also is to
look in the mirror and look into your
own eyes and start with something really
simple but difficult like I love you I
really really love you and most people
can't do that at all because it's just
too painful they have all these messages
back here that says you're no good and
you can't be in beside you your makeup
isn't on right or you forgot to shave
today or something you know but once you
can do that if you do it over and over
again for a while it's like you connect
on a different level with that inner
child who's been waiting for years and
years and years for you to acknowledge
it yeah and something happens and I
couldn't tell you what it is but I have
learned that people who do their
affirmations in front of a mirror make
much quicker progress than other people
yeah yeah it just it pushes through when
life calls us
that's when we have to answer people say
how did you do everything that you did
well I answered the telephone and opened
the mail
and did what what was in front of me
and then life would give me something
else to do and something else to do
and it's interesting because it's now
been I think 25 years since I wrote the
second book you can heal your life
and in that period of time I that book
alone has sold 40 million copies
worldwide
[Applause]
[Music]
and I feel I've always felt that I
didn't do anything to promote it at all
it's just life took over and life said
this book is going to go to this country
and this book is going to go to this
country and go to this country and
it's gone many many places all over the
world I even have two Chinese versions
there's this Chinese version of
traditional China and then there's the
Chinese version of the Taiwan which is
the new China
you never know where life is going to
take your work
and I think that it's important that you
don't go into it to say how much money
can I make oh I'm going to be rich I've
got to do this because books don't make
you that rich
but what they do is open the world to
you
and my thought has always been how can I
help the people how can I help the
people
and I think if you come from that point
of view it becomes a lot easier
gratitude works a lot just being
grateful for everything the more I
always say the universe loves gratitude
the more you're grateful for what the
good is in your life the more good you
get to be grateful about and it's like
you know if somebody gives you a present
and your or gives me a present and I say
oh my God I hate that color and it
doesn't fit and you know that person
will never give me another present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you I really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves gratitude for those of
people that have tried to change their
thinking but seem to be stuck and can
you give them some advice to help them
to be more positive or to get through
well I don't think that they've been
trying and they're stuck I think they
just haven't tried because if you will
practice this even a small amount it
makes a difference I have a simple
exercise I give everybody and some
people say oh that's so stupid it's so
silly but I asked them to look in the
mirror especially first thing in the
morning and just look in their eyes and
say their name and say I love you I
really really love you
and this is enormously hard for most
people to do to begin with but as you
continue to do it it makes a big
difference you see life loves you life
really loves you but if you don't love
yourself it's very hard for life to
bring you the goodies because you've got
this wall up so when you can learn to
love who you are and that's the way you
were born when you were a little tiny
baby and when I say you I mean everybody
listening to this we all adored
ourselves we loved our bodies we loved
every part of ourselves and then we
started to listen to other people who
told us we weren't good enough or we
didn't do it right or no no no and so
we've decided that maybe we weren't very
good and that's where we get all mixed
up but when we can get back to that
point of just adoring this marvelous
Critter in here uh then life says oh
she's got it she's got it let's give her
goodies and then the next step is to be
very grateful about it yes when you're
really grateful then they want to give
you more when I work with people when I
workshops or classes or anything I
always try to get people just to open
their arms so that we can let the new
one remember this is the subconscious
mind and this is where we're holding
so this is saying nothing new will get
in so I always like to feel that I'm
open and receptive to new ideas and I'm
willing to learn and I'm willing to
change and I'm willing to grow and
sometimes I don't want to and sometimes
it hits areas that I don't really care
to change at the moment and you know
that's always an area that I know is
important for me to work on to me I
think Enlightenment is letting go of all
the things we believe that are not
benefiting us us in Life or there are
barriers to our life to the good things
in life and to release them one by one
and to think
I don't have to believe that anymore or
do I want to believe that anymore and
making a conscious Choice when we can
understand that every single thing we
believe has been a choice
and it may or may not be true it can be
true for you and not for you
because it's your belief system and your
belief system and then I have my belief
system I say a lot that may be true for
you it's not true for me I may not say
that out loud but people are doing
things they're saying things and I think
that to myself a lot and also it has
nothing to do with me
whatever's going that has nothing to do
with me because I'm under the law of my
own Consciousness this is my pathway and
you have your pathway you have yours
everybody does so we're all on a journey
and I think
the more conscientious we are about it
and the more conscious choices we make
the better our journey is or the easier
or the swifter or the we get more
goodies or we have better health if you
have very strong beliefs within you that
you don't deserve good things in your
life and a lot of people have that then
there can be delays
and sometimes people say well
affirmations don't work I've done them
but when they're doing for instance
Prosperity affirmations and they've done
some Prosperity affirmations and they
say it doesn't work nothing's happening
and I say well all right how many
Prosperity affirmations did you do in a
day and they'll say three probably and
they say all right how many poverty
affirmations did you do this day
and that could be 300 depending on where
you're coming from and what are is
running through your mind
see I have this one of my thoughts about
life is that only good lies before me
and I've been saying this for many years
so it doesn't really matter to me what
happens in life because I know it's
going to be good remember little tiny
babies when they're born they absolutely
adore themselves and they're totally
open and they're full of love
[Music]
they express themselves freely they ask
for what they want
they love their bodies from the top of
the toe to the top of their head to the
tip of their toes and every point in
between including their own feces which
they'll gladly rub all over their bodies
because nobody's taught them guilt and
shame
they know how wonderful they are
and then somewhere along the line we get
this idea that we're not good enough and
we start putting our tape measures
around our waistline to tell us if we're
acceptable or we read magazines that say
we have to be a certain height or a
certain weight before we're acceptable
or we listen to the media that says we
have to use a certain deodorant before
we're acceptable you know it just
doesn't make sense
we are absolutely Divine magnificent
expressions of Life all of us and like
when we were in the circle looking at
each other we each face is another
unique expression of God
and we're not supposed to be alike
since time began on this planet there
have not been two snowflakes alike
and there's certainly not been two
people alike and we're always trying to
be like everybody else so we're
acceptable our uniqueness is what makes
us wonderful
so we want to love that and cherish it
and acknowledge it because if we really
believe in our uniqueness and The Wonder
of each being then there is no
competition and no comparison there
can't be we're just different and we're
meant to be different and that's
wonderful I went to a Chinese face
reading class recently and one of the
things they talked about was a bossy
woman cheekbones and I said that's me
that's me
woman cheekbones and all my life life I
used to call them polish cheekbones now
I know they're bossy woman cheekbones
but in and also in Chinese uh astrology
I'm a fire tiger
now the tiger is a very strong
personality and a fire tiger is a very
strong personality and but in the early
days in China they used to kill the
girls who were fire Tigers because they
didn't want them to grow up and tell
people what to do
ah so this time I've come forth and I
get to be who I am a fire tiger with
bossy woman cheekbones that is so cool I
think we get we all get certain ahas
and that's when we've sort of learned
something we say oh okay and then if we
can keep that
what we've learned and practice it then
we've made another step and we can move
forward
um
yes it's a lifetime journey and we never
stop learning I'm 80 and I'm still
learning
no the lessons are easier now than they
used to be I like to think of it when we
start we have all these Boulders in
front of us on our pathway and we start
to get the boulders out of the way and
you finally get to the point where it's
gravel and gravel you can handle
you know and you can sweep gravel and
you can do things
so
and then occasionally there's an old
Boulder
I thought I
had that one but not completely
and and you know also I think that when
we learn lessons we think oh I've
learned that one it'll never happen
again I've done that and that's it
well how do you know you've done it
unless it comes by once more and see how
you react have you really learned it is
it really nothing for you have you gone
beyond that or are you going to go right
back into the same old reaction
see we're never wrong that's what we
need to learn that we're always doing
the best we can with the understanding
and awareness and knowledge we have at
that moment if you're in a job you don't
like if you're in a relationship you
don't like if you're in a a house you
don't like
and you want something new begin to
bless with love
interesting to blessed with love where
you are
and and know that you're releasing your
current situation with love if it's a
job release it with love to the next
person who will be delighted to have it
if it's an apartment do the same thing
if it's a relationship release that
person with love to happiness which is
Meaningful to them
and that leaves you free to create and
accept happiness that is Meaningful to
you you say you have to start with
beginning to love yourself I think you
hear a lot of that in the 80s and what
the what does that mean it means to stop
putting yourself down stop criticizing
yourself stop mistreating yourself begin
to treat yourself as something that's
very precious and when you begin to love
who you are then you can love your
neighbor because you love yourself you
see I don't think we can really love our
neighbor till we do love ourselves the
Bible says that and is it love that
heals or is it that something that
happens inside you that I think love
opens the space it opens the way for you
to create healing for yourself if it is
true that your thoughts shape your life
would you want what you were just
thinking right now to become true for
you if it's a thought of worry or anger
or hurt or revenge or fear
how do you think this thought will come
back to you if you hear yourself
expressing negative words of any sort
stop in mid-sentence either rephrase the
sentence or just drop it you could even
say to it out you get to choose any and
all thoughts you wish these thoughts
create your future experiences
let us stay away from thoughts that
create problems and pain some of you
know my little blue book and the fact
that I've been doing a lot of work with
dis-ease for a long time and for every
part of the body there is a mental
pattern and for every dis-ease in the
body there is a mental pattern and when
you know what they are you can begin to
change the mental patterns so that
you can change the dis-ease you see we
don't want to be sick no that's a
blanket statement sometimes people do
want to be sick because it's a good way
to get out of something
the rest of us know how to say no if you
don't know how to say no you may have to
create an illness in order to say no
because that's we've made in society
we've made that a legitimate way of
getting out of things
but basically we do not want to be ill
and yet we need every dis-ease that we
have because it is the body's way of
telling us that there is a false idea in
Consciousness something that we're doing
something that we're believing something
that we're saying is not for our highest
good and the body is saying please
and it's sort of almost like tugging
saying pay attention
so
[Music]
when we know what these patterns are it
gives us again a choice of whether we
wish to do something about it or not
there are lots of things you can do to
help you become more conscious of what
is going on and because so many of our
belief systems really are unconscious or
subconscious we're not aware of them
they're just things that were bred into
us as we were children is to take a
little time to figure out what they are
and I always say a really good exercise
is to take a big sheet of paper and
write on top of it say what I think
about men and then another one what I
think about women what do I think about
money what do I think about any subject
you can think of and just write all the
things that come down come out of your
thoughts and whether they sound good or
not just write them down
and
any one subject if you just write them
all down and then look at them and see
how many are positive and how many are
negative and if you can take those
negative ones and turn them around make
them into positive affirmations then you
can start clearing up what you believe
about say money that is not positive for
you
Henry or is keeping you from bringing
money in
and you can do that with lots of things
in your life so you can really begin to
realize what you do believe about these
things
so you can't change your thoughts if you
don't know what your thoughts are
there is a law of thinking and we are
beginning to learn about it and it is
like a computer if you have this
gorgeous computer put in front of you
and you don't know what to do with it
it's a piece of junk but if you learn
the language of the computer miracles
happen
and that is what the law of thinking is
when you learn how it works
miracles happen
what you think
and what you believe it's what will come
true for you your thoughts create your
life
it's that simple and when we can get
that we can make enormous changes Stop
scaring yourself
how often do you terrorize yourself with
your own thoughts
you get into absolute Terror and it's
only coming from your thoughts nobody
out there is doing a thing sometimes
it's an old family pattern sometimes we
get new things I would like people when
you have time to make a list of your
fears
make a list of your fears and then give
yourself the opportunity to turn each
fear into a positive affirmation
turn each one into something positive
and remember always you are in charge
you are always in charge
[Music]
see one idle thought doesn't make a
whole lot of difference thoughts are
like drops of water you drop a drop of
water and it doesn't mean much but if
you keep dropping and keep dropping you
get puddle on the floor
and then you can get a little pond and a
lake and finally you can create an ocean
and with our own thoughts we can drown
in a sea of negativity
or we can float on the ocean of life
and it's up to us the thoughts we think
accumulate and what sort of Puddles Are
you standing in or are you up to here or
are you up to here and trying to paddle
you know what are you doing to yourself
when we're willing to change our
thinking we can change our experiences
and it doesn't matter if you've got a
big puddle of negative thoughts you know
you can move over here and create a
puddle of mindfulness positive thoughts
you can make changes always so you want
to turn those fear thoughts into
positive affirmations
let them work for you I have a thing
when I was seeing people that I got to
the point where I would not see anyone
who did not make their own appointment
I have found occasionally people have
sent people to me as a present oh you
must go see Louise here I'll give it to
you as a present every one of those has
turned out to be a disaster
half the time the people didn't turn up
when they did turn up they weren't
really interested when they seemed to be
interested they never went away and did
anything or if they did it was a little
bit and they never came back
we have to be ready to do it ourselves
remember each person has come to this
planet to learn a lesson you have your
lessons you have your lessons I have my
lessons you have your lessons they're
all different
we cannot learn the other person's
lessons we are not here to change other
people we are here to change ourself
that is what we've come to the planet
for to change ourself
if we try to do it for someone else or
learn their lesson or make it nice
they don't get to learn it
and even if we fix it isn't it amazing
how they turn around and recreate it
again and we all know people like that
we've paid their rent or we've gotten
them out of some mess or we've done this
for them or that form
and two months later they're in the same
problem because it's their pattern
it has nothing to do teaching them how
to get out of it it is much better if
they're willing to learn
so it's like you know the student must
come to the teacher and when the student
is ready the teacher is there always I
think it really starts with realizing
that you don't love yourself that most
people don't most people feel they're
not good enough that they haven't done
it right they won't do it right they'll
never be enough and they're definitely
not lovable and when we come from that
space it's very hard to create things
for ourselves that are really good so in
the early days when I worked with people
I used to fix this problem and fix that
problem and you'd have this a health
thing and we'd work on that and we'd
work on this and one day I discovered
much to my amazement that if I would
help people learn to love themselves to
really accept themselves as they are we
didn't have to work around problems
because it was almost like a miracle
everything seemed to fall away it's a
hard one for people because we're
we grow up believing that we're not good
enough and nothing is right
I remember lots of times I would ask
people well what is really wrong with
you what have you done that is so
terrible that you're not acceptable to
yourself and I never ever ever got an
answer that made any sense you know they
might say something like well I'm too
fat well so it's you know but
I when you talk about loving yourself a
lot of people think that that's vanity
but it isn't really it has nothing to do
with that that is narcissistic but to
really care for you and to acknowledge
that you are an important being it's
almost like in the Bible they would say
you recognize that you are a child of
God that therefore you are perfect but
even if you're not a Biblical person if
you can recognize that you are a being
that has self-worth if you can really
recognize your own worth then you start
to treat yourself differently and I
think that's what's so very important
about loving yourself is you stop
beating yourself up you stop making
yourself wrong you stop talking about
how awful you are and you stop saying
things like I'm really stupid and stuff
and you start to treat yourself with a
certain amount of respect and this makes
an enormous difference because what you
give out in life is what comes back to
you
so if you're giving out a feeling of I'm
okay I'm good enough as I am and I am
acceptable and I love life and I love me
and you start having gratitude for
yourself and for life then life treats
you differently because you are having a
different vibration that you're giving
out and getting back
and that's when things really start to
flow now a lot of people don't realize
it but you have to practice you just
have to start it and that's why I try to
get people to do a lot of mirror work if
you look in the mirror just simple
things like looking in the mirror in
your own eyes and saying I love you I
really really love you and it helps if
you use your name Louise I love you I
really love you it gets to that little
child inside that has been rejected for
so long and it breaks open sort of a dam
or a door or whatever you want to call
it and it's like Little Miracles start
to happen lots of little good things
happen and the universe loves grateful
people the more grateful you are the
more you get to be grateful about people
think that Prosperity is Just money but
really there's many many other things
that come under this auspices of
prosperity
you know you can be very poor in time if
you feel really rushed all the time and
always pressured you have poverty in
your time but if you feel that you have
all the time in the world and that
whatever you want to finish you'll get
done and it will it will all happen then
you're really prosperous in time and
what about success you know if you feel
that it's really Way Beyond your reach
then you're never going to get it but if
you feel that you can be successful
whatever that means to you then that's
wonderful that's Prosperity wisdom do
you have prosperity and wisdom do you
feel that all the wisdom in the universe
is available to you or do you think oh
I'm just me and I don't know very much
and you know I can't figure things out
if you feel that you're really connected
with the universe and you really trust
that part of you that's inside then you
can be absolutely prosperous in the
abundance of wisdom and What About Love
do you feel that you I have an abundance
of Love or are you very poor in love is
there very just a little bit of it in
your life how about Joy
do you feel you're really prosperous and
I have an abundance of Joy or is that
something you just allow yourself a
little bit of now and then
you really are very poor in joy and then
what about beauty do you see beauty
everywhere do you allow yourself to
experience an abundance of beauty
and of course there's money then there's
money too you know what do you let
yourself have I like to use that uh
image a lot of the ocean standing in
front of the ocean with a container in
your hand you know and you're there and
you have this container but what is it
is it a thimble with a hole in it is it
a small cracked cup is it a mug is it a
Voz but no matter how much you have
whatever your container it is and no
matter how much you're taking from the
ocean of life and even though we're all
standing there we're not robbing each
other and there's plenty for everyone
and no matter how much we take there is
no way we're going to run that Ocean
Drive it's absolutely impossible and if
you can see yourself standing at the
ocean of life in the same way and
remember the container that you have is
your Consciousness and you can always
change your Consciousness and it doesn't
matter if you came with poverty doesn't
matter where you came from and it
doesn't even matter what your parents
beliefs were because it's your
Consciousness and what you're choosing
to think and mean about prosperity and
your ability to deserve it is what's
going to create it for you so many
people think that money is the most
important thing in the world if they
don't have money they would just die but
that's not true there's a substance that
is far more precious and far more
important to us that we literally can't
live without what is that
love no plenty of people are miserable
and lonely most of their life and and
and live
air your air your breath your breath is
the most important thing that you have
the most precious thing if you didn't
take another breath you wouldn't last
three minutes and you'd never get out of
this room and yet we absolutely take for
granted
that our next breath is there look at us
we're all in this room breathing and I'm
not saying don't breathe there's not
enough for me we assume that it's there
and when we exhale we don't think about
where's my next breath coming from
now
if the power that created us has given
us enough breath to last for as long as
we shall live
can we not begin to trust that the other
things will take care of themselves
see life is here for us life is here to
support us to take care of us to be here
for us the entire planet has been put
here for us to play with we have
everything that we shall ever need it's
already here only we have to know it and
we have to trust it and we have to
acknowledge it do you realize that there
is more food on this planet than people
could possibly eat there's an incredible
amount of food yes it is true that there
are people starving
the food is here
there is more money on this planet than
we know how to count
the money is here now there are lots of
people who are very broke but the money
is here
there are billions of people on this
planet
and yet you will have people tell you
that they're lonely
it has nothing to do with not being
people
it's what we're doing with our heads
everything is here for us for every
dis-ease on this planet there is a plant
that will cure it
everything everything is here for us and
the more we begin to trust life and
acknowledge the beauty and magnificence
of our own being the more we find
everything we need it just pops up to
begin with you start by doing what we
call doing affirmations and that is
making positive statements about your
life that are positive and you do them
deliberately you might do them in the
morning you might do them at noon you
might do them at night you might do them
you know twice a day or whatever but you
do this and you let this become a habit
and as you start to do them things will
begin to change maybe on a very small
level I call it getting the green lights
from the parking places I mean they're
not huge things in your life they can be
very nice when you get three green
lights in a row and you're in a hurry
doing an affirmation is either writing
it down writing it on the wall or the
mirror or using a you know just saying
it what I like people to do is to stand
in front of a mirror and do their
affirmations because there's something
very powerful about looking in your own
eyes
and getting and accepting yourself or
noticing that you reject yourself when
you're saying something positive about
yourself so that would be a very
beginning way to start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror and this is
a big one and it's hard for lots of
people
but you look in the mirror and I say and
say I love you I really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them but if you can start your day
saying that it's very powerful remember
I'd like to think the universe is
listening to everything you say and
everything you think and saying okay you
can get that so then it starts to bring
you in and bring things into you and I
know this sounds far to fetched but it's
amazing how it works you if you do a
good generals positive statement for
yourself
the universe will figure out how to
manifest that how to bring that about in
your life so things could happen that
you wouldn't expect at all but they will
happen
if you think of doing your positive
affirmations is like planting a seed in
the ground it's not necessarily true at
the moment but it is something you want
to have be true so you put the seed in
and you you you plant a seed and you
expect it to grow
or you maybe plant three seeds just in
case you expect them to grow and you
don't wait for two days and then dig in
the earth and say what's happening
what's happening you expect that thing
to grow because you know there's a law
and a process and the seed will grow if
it is in the right soil and it has the
right amount of moisture
you can get really a habit and doing it
every day doing something every morning
when you wake up that's a really good
time and another good time is when you
go to sleep at night the thoughts we
think and the words we speak are
constantly shaping our world and our
experiences many of us aren't an old
habit of negative thinking and do not
realize the damage we have inflicted
upon ourselves however we are never
stuck because we can always change our
thinking
as we learn to consistently choose
positive thoughts the old negative ones
dissolve away
so as you listen to the following power
thoughts let the affirmations and ideas
wash over your Consciousness your
subconscious mind will pick up the ones
that are important to you at the moment
the
SE steps are like fertilizing the soil
of your mind as you absorb them by
repetition you are slowly enriching the
very basis of your garden of life
anything you plant will grow abundantly
I see you vibrant and healthy surrounded
by exquisite beauty living a life of
love and prosperity filled with joy and
laughter you are on a wonderful pathway
of change and growth
enjoy your trip
[Music]
my healing is already in process
your body knows how to heal itself get
the negative garbage out of the way then
love your body feed it nourishing foods
and beverages pamper it respect it
create an atmosphere of Wellness allow
yourself to heal lungs have to do with
taking in life
this is the breath of life this is where
we take in life and we have the ability
to take in just enough to get us by or
we can fill our lungs and really have
all the cells in the body work well in
our brain cells work well
traditionally for generations and
generations women have been very shallow
breathers because we bought this story
that said we're not good enough that
we're second-class citizens and we began
to believe that we didn't have the right
to take up very much space and we barely
had the right to exist and so we take in
just about enough air to keep us going
that's changing now and it's wonderful
and one of the things that really
excites me today is what's happening
with women in the gyms you know we have
worked in the fields for a very long
time but I think this is the first time
that I'm aware of where women have
really gone out for sports and you see
some of the female bodies in the gyms
these days that go out and exercise they
are incredibly magnificent and just
wonderful and they're taking in life and
taking up space and taking air and I
think it's beautiful so people who have
lung problems people who smoke too much
people have emphysema and things like
that they're cutting life off they're
saying on some level I don't deserve to
exist
around you deserve to exist a little bit
if you want to create Better Health in
your body there are definitely some
things you must not do you must not get
angry at your body for any reason anger
is another affirmation and it is telling
your body that you hate it or hate parts
of it your cells are very aware of every
thought you have
think of your body as a servant that is
working as hard as it can to keep you in
perfect health no matter how you treat
it your body knows how to heal itself if
you feed it healthy foods and Beverages
and give it exercise and sufficient
sleep and think happy thoughts then it's
work is easy the cells are working in a
happy healthy atmosphere however if you
feed it junk foods and drink lots of
diet soda be a couch potato and skimp on
sleep and are grouchy and complaining
all the time then the cells in your body
are working at a disadvantage and in a
disagreeable atmosphere then it's no
wonder that your body is not as healthy
as you would like it to be
you will never create good health by
talking or thinking about your illness
good health comes from Love and
appreciation you want to put as much
love into your body as you possibly can
talk to it in loving ways touch and
stroke it in loving ways if there is a
part of your body that is ailing or
diseased then you want to treat it as
you would a sick little child tell it
how much you love it and that you are
doing everything you can to help it get
well quickly
if you are sick then you want to do more
than just go to the doctor and have him
give you a chemical to take care of the
symptom your body is telling you that
something you are doing is not good for
your body
you need to learn more about health the
more you learn the easier it is to take
care of your body
you do not want to choose to feel like a
victim that just gives your power away
you could go to a health food store and
pick up one of the many good books that
teach you how to keep yourself healthy
you could see a nutritionist and have a
healthy diet created just for you or you
could see a holistic health practitioner
do create a healthy happy mental
atmosphere be a willing participant in
your own health plan
I believe we create every so-called
illness in our body the body like
everything else in life is a mirror of
our inner thoughts and beliefs the body
is always talking to us if we will only
take the time to listen gratitude works
a lot of just being grateful for
everything the more I always say the
universe loves gratitude the more you're
grateful for what the good is in your
life the more good you get to be
grateful about
and it's it's like you know if somebody
gives you a present in your or gives me
a present and I say oh my God I hate
that color and it doesn't fit and you
know that person will never give me
another present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you I really adored it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves gratitude I trust my
inner wisdom there is a place within
each of us that is totally connected
with the infinite wisdom of the universe
in this place lie all the answers to all
the questions you will ever ask learn to
trust your inner self
as I go about my daily Affairs I listen
to my own guidance my intuition is
always on my side I trust it to be there
at all times I am safe continuous modes
of thinking and speaking produce body
behaviors and postures and eases or
diseases the person who has a
permanently scowling face did not
produce that by having joyous Loving
Thoughts older people's faces and bodies
show so clearly a lifetime of thinking
patterns how will you look when you are
elderly
learn to accept that your life is not a
series of random events but a pathway of
Awakening if every day is an Awakening
you will never grow old you will just
keep growing imagine the day you turned
49 as the infancy of another life
a woman today who reaches the age 50 and
remains free of cancer and heart disease
can expect to see her 92nd birthday
you and only you have the ability to
customize your own life cycle so change
your thinking now and get going you are
here for a very important reason and all
you need is available to you
you can create thoughts that create a
mental atmosphere that contributes to
illness
or you can choose to think thoughts that
create a healthy atmosphere both within
you and around you if you have very
strong beliefs within you that you don't
deserve good things in your life and a
lot of people have that then there can
be delays
and sometimes people say well
affirmations don't work I've done them
but when they're doing for instance
Prosperity affirmations and they've done
some Prosperity affirmations and they
say it doesn't work nothing's happening
and I say well all right how many
Prosperity affirmations did you do in a
day and they'll say three probably and
they say all right how many poverty
affirmations did you do this day
and that could be 300 depending on where
you're coming from and what are is
running through your mind
see I have this one of my thoughts about
life is that only good lies before me
and I've been saying this for many years
so it doesn't really matter to me what
happens in life because I know it's
going to be good I am deeply fulfilled
by all that I do we will never have the
opportunity to live this day again so we
want to savor every moment there is
richness and fullness in everything we
do each moment of the day is special to
me as I follow my higher instincts and
listen to my heart I am at peace in my
world and Affairs
I trust the process of life
we are learning how life works it's like
learning your computer when you first
get a computer you learn the simple
basic processes how to turn it on and
off and how to open and save a document
how to print and on that level your
computer works wonders for you and yet
there is so much more that it can do for
you when you learn more of its ways it's
the same thing with life the more we
learn how it works the more wonders it
performs for us
there is a rhythm and flow to life and I
am part of it life supports me and
brings me only good and positive
experiences I trust the process of life
to bring me my highest good I teach
people to love themselves
because I find that this is the answer
for almost everything
[Music]
you see I believe that we're all one
hundred percent responsible for
everything in our lives I think we
create all of our experiences by our
thinking feeling patterns the thoughts
we think and the words we speak are
enormously powerful and it's almost as
though we think of thought or we speak a
word and it goes out from us and it
comes back to us as experience
now we learn how we feel about ourselves
and how we feel about life when we are
very very little by the time we are
three to five years old we have a total
mindset about who we are and what life
is all about and from then on we keep
reacting to experiences through this
mindset
and while very often these thoughts that
we have and these beliefs that we create
or decisions that we make or agreements
that we make at that age are very good
and they help us to survive in what may
be a very difficult situation
we often take them forward into life so
that when we become adults we're still
operating out of a three-year-old
mentality or a three-year-old decision
and that often doesn't work in our life
so we learn these things when we're very
young and we usually learn them from our
parents and this is not to blame them
because I really do believe that we're
all victims of victims and it isn't
possible for anybody to teach us
anything that they don't know if your
mother didn't know how to love herself
there's no way she could teach you how
to love yourself and if your father
didn't know how to love himself then he
couldn't teach you how to love yourself
and if you grew up in a family that was
very angry or frightened then you're
likely to be an angry or frightened
person because that's what you learned
as a child it's not right or wrong or
good or bad it just is again it doesn't
matter what the problem is or how long
you've had it or how difficult or
chronic it is or anything else or
whether it's brand new or whether it
runs in the family there's only one
thing I ever teach anyone and that is
loving the self because when we really
love and appreciate and acknowledge who
we are at this point in time and space
it's like little miracles happen
everywhere
and life begins to flow for us and we do
what I call getting the green lights in
the parking places and all those little
things that make life so wonderful and
when we don't love and appreciate who we
are then we put up the barriers and the
resistance to our own good now I'm not
talking about vanity because that or
arrogance because that is not love that
is fear I'm just talking about
appreciating the being that we are so
many people ask me about how to love
yourself how do you love yourself Luis
because I talk about it all the time so
I made a list of how to love yourself
and it's even in poster and postcard
form now but number one on that list of
How To Love Yourself is to stop all
criticism just stop it now and
forevermore and make a vow to yourself
that you're going to do your very best
from now on to stop criticizing number
one you
and then other people
it'll be a lot easier to stop
criticizing other people when you stop
criticizing yourself
two on that list is stopped scaring
yourself
and here we go into fear how often do
you terrorize yourself with your own
thoughts
foreign
you get into absolute Terror and it's
only coming from your thoughts nobody
out there is doing a thing sometimes
it's an old family pattern sometimes we
get new things how many people here are
absolutely in Terror of earthquakes
then how often do you do that to
yourself
you know we find so many ways to scare
ourselves I would like people when you
have time to make a list of your fears
make a list of your fears and then give
yourself the opportunity to turn each
fear into a positive affirmation
turn each one into something positive
and remember always you are in charge
you are always in charge
see one idle thought doesn't make a
whole lot of difference it's like a but
thoughts are like drops of water
you drop a drop of water on the table
here and it doesn't mean much but if you
keep dropping and keep dropping and
treat dropping you get the table becomes
a wash and then you get a puddle on the
floor
and then you can get a little pond and a
lake and finally you can create an ocean
and with our own thoughts we can drown
in a sea of negativity
or we can float on the ocean of life
and it's up to us
the thoughts we think accumulate and
what sort of Puddles Are you standing in
or are you up to here or are you up to
here and trying to paddle
you know what are you doing to yourself
when we're willing to change our
thinking we can change our experiences
and it doesn't matter if you've got a
big puddle of negative thoughts you know
you can move over here and create a
puddle of mindfulness positive thoughts
you can make changes always
so you want to turn those fear thoughts
into positive affirmations
let them work for you doing an
affirmation is either writing it down
writing it on the wall or the mirror or
using a you know just saying it what I
like people to do is to stand in front
of a mirror and do their affirmations
because there's something very powerful
about looking in your own eyes and
getting and accepting yourself or
noticing that you reject yourself when
you're saying something positive about
yourself so that would be a very
beginning way to start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror and this is
a big one and it's hard for lots of
people but you look in the mirror and I
say and say I love you
I really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them but if you can start your day
saying that it's very powerful
remember I'd like to think the universe
is listening to everything you say and
everything you think and saying okay you
can get that
so then it starts to bring you in and
bring things into you and I know this
sounds far-fetched but it's amazing how
it works you if you do a good generals
positive statement for yourself
the universe will figure out how to
manifest that how to bring that about in
your life so things could happen that
you wouldn't expect at all but they will
happen
if you think of doing your positive
affirmations is like planting a seed in
the ground it's not necessarily true at
the moment but it is something you want
to have be true
so you put the seed in
and you you you plant a seed and you
expect it to grow
or you maybe plant three seeds just in
case you expect them to grow and you
don't wait for two days and then dig in
the earth and say what's happening
what's happening you expect that thing
to grow because you know there's a law
and a process and the seed will grow if
it is in the right soil and it has the
right amount of moisture
making it really a habit and doing it
every day doing something every morning
when you wake up that's a really good
time and another good time is when you
go to sleep at night and and gratitude
works a lot if just being grateful for
everything the more I always say the
universe loves gratitude the more you're
grateful for what the good is in your
life the more good you get to be
grateful about and it's it's like you
know if somebody gives you a present in
your or gives me a present and I say oh
my God I hate that color and it doesn't
fit and you know that person will never
give me another present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you I really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves gratitude we have to be
ready to do it ourselves
remember each person has come to this
planet to learn a lesson you have your
lessons you have your lessons I have my
lessons you have your lessons they're
all different
we cannot learn the other person's
lessons we are not here to change other
people we are here to change ourself
that is what we've come to the planet
for to change ourself
if we try to do it for someone else or
learn their lesson or make it nice
they don't get to learn it
and even if we fix it isn't it amazing
how they turn around and recreate it
again and we all know people like that
we've paid their rent or we've gotten
them out of some mess or we've done this
for them or that form
and two months later they're in the same
problem because it's their pattern
it has nothing to do teaching them how
to get out of it it is much better if
they're willing to learn
so it's like you know the student must
come to the teacher and when the student
is ready the teacher is there always you
see I believe that life is really very
simple what we give out we get back and
what we believe about ourselves becomes
true for us
our thinking creates our experiences
there is a law of thinking like
everything else like all of nature there
is a universal energy or law of mind or
subconscious mind whatever you want to
call it but to me it means the power
that is within me and around me
transforms my thoughts into experiences
you see I believe that we are all
responsible for everything in our lives
every thought we think and every word we
speak is creating our experiences our
future and it's almost as though every
time you think a thought or you speak a
word that Universal intelligence or
energy is listening or responding to
what you are thinking or believing or
saying without judgment or criticism
totally accepting us at our own value
whatever we choose to believe becomes
true for us there are lots of things you
can do to help you become more conscious
of what is going on and because so many
of our belief systems really are
unconscious or subconscious we're not
aware of them they're just things that
were bred into us as we were children is
to take a little time to figure out what
they are and I always say a really good
exercise is to take a big sheet your
paper and write on top of it say what I
think about men and then another one
what I think about women what do I think
about money what do I think about any
subject you can think of and just write
all the things that come down come out
of your thoughts and whether they sound
good or not just write them down
and
any one subject if you just write them
all down and then look at them and see
how many are positive and how many are
negative and if you can take those
negative ones and turn them around make
them into positive affirmations then you
can start clearing up what you believe
about say money that is not positive for
you
and or is keeping you from bringing
money in uh and and you can do that with
lots of things in your life so you can
really begin to realize what you do
believe about these things
so you can't change your thoughts if you
don't know what your thoughts are
there is a law of thinking and we are
beginning to learn about it and it is
like a computer if you have this
gorgeous computer put in front of you
and you don't know what to do with it
it's a piece of junk but if you learn
the language of the computer miracles
happen
and that is what the law of thinking is
when you learn how it works
miracles happen
what you think
and what you believe it's what will come
true for you your thoughts create your
life
it's that simple and when we can get
that we can make enormous changes if you
think for a moment about the vastness of
the universe it is so incredibly big
that our human Minds cannot comprehend
it it is enormous and even our most our
top scientists with the most up-to-date
equipment today cannot measure the size
of the universe and half of them won't
agree on whether it's expanding or
Contracting
and in this Incredible Universe there
are so many galaxies that we haven't
counted all of them and in one of the
smaller galaxies in a far-off corner
there is a it called the small Galaxy
called a Milky Way in a very far off
corner there is a minor Sun
and around this Sun revolve a few
pinpoints
one of which is called planet Earth
now I find it very very hard to believe
that the incredible intelligence that
created this entire universe
is an old man sitting on a cloud above
the planet earth watching my genitals
[Laughter]
and yet it doesn't compute it does not
compute and yet how many of us were
raised to believe that
thank you
and many of us are living it if you were
raised in a religion where you were a
sinner and a worm and you had a lot of
sexual problems and things like that
start to re-evaluate do some mental work
to change that so that you're not still
operating you can sit down in front of a
mirror would be real good look in your
eyes and say okay now when I was a kid
this is what I was taught but I'm not a
child anymore now I am adult and I don't
believe that I now choose to believe and
then decide what you want your belief of
God to be like
you see if you're in a religion
that puts you down or where you are a
sinner or a worm or whatever get another
religion
there are plenty of them they all tell
you that they're the only way
I see I think even our concept of God
must support us
and you do not have to have the same
concept of God that your parents had or
your grandparents had you don't have to
each person is a unique individual and
each one of us creates our own lifestyle
and our own belief system and it's
I think we need to constantly
re-evaluate what we believe
and particularly if we believe things
that don't nourish us
think why do I believe that where did I
learn that does is that really true for
me now does it make sense maybe I could
let that one go
you might create a pair of psychic
scissors and cut them out of your
Consciousness or create a great big
waste basket and say okay that one goes
there
and decide that you just do not choose
to live under old limitations anymore
[Music]
refuse to believe in worry
begin to trust the universe and watch
how it works I've had many people tell
me well because of such and such I can
no longer enjoy life I didn't get
invited to the prom or the party so now
I'm going to be miserable for the rest
of my life or I didn't get the part or I
didn't make the sale so I'm no good
or because I'm no longer married I can't
enjoy life ever again what foolish
limitations we create for ourselves
don't let these beliefs from the past
hurt you in the now release that
emotional attachment
if we live fully in this moment we
cannot be hurt by the past no matter
what it was
if I asked you what you wore in the
third grade you may or may not remember
if you remember you probably wouldn't
have much emotional attachment to it you
would just remember and that would be it
and that's how we want to be with all
our past experiences just recognize them
and let them go when we go on a
spiritual journey it seems to be more
conscious and we begin to make conscious
choices about life instead of just going
on and getting up in the morning and
doing our stuff and then going to bed we
began to make conscious choices of our
our thoughts and our actions and even
the foods we eat and things like that
and it's putting your foot on the
pathway one step at a time
and some of us will do very devious
Journeys and we take lots of little Side
Tracks and we don't get very far really
and some of us just are very
conscientious about it and go one step
after another and go closer to our
pathway which is really
um to me I think Enlightenment is
letting go of all the things we believe
that are not benefiting us us in Life or
the barriers to our life to the good
things in life and to release them one
by one and just think
I don't have to believe that anymore or
do I want to believe that anymore and
making a conscious Choice when we can
understand that every single thing we
believe has been a choice
and it may or may not be true it can be
true for you and not for you
because it's your belief system and your
belief system and that I have my belief
system I say a lot that may be true for
you it's not true for me I may not say
that out loud but people are doing
things they're saying things and I think
that to myself a lot and also it has
nothing to do with me
whatever's going that has nothing to do
with me because I'm under the law of my
own Consciousness this is my pathway and
you have your pathway you have yours
everybody does so we're all on a journey
and I think
the more conscientious we are about it
and the more conscious choices we make
the better our journey is or the easier
or the swifter or the we get more
goodies or we have better health
all that stuff I believe that we choose
our parents I think we decide to
Incarnate upon this planet at particular
points in time and space and we come
here because it's like a classroom
we have lessons to learn you have your
lessons and I have my lessons and so
before we come each time I believe we
choose our sex we choose our color we
choose our country and then we look
around for the perfect set of parents
that will mirror the lessons and
patterns we came to work on
we choose these people as the perfect
mirror for our work
than most of us when we grow up have a
tendency to point our fingers at our
parents and say you did it to me it's
all your fault but really if we're all
responsible for everything in our lives
then there's no one to blame all is in
perfect Divine Right order
and we are all doing our best according
to the understanding awareness and
knowledge that we have
our point
hour is always in the present moment
we create our future by our thoughts and
actions of today
and we can know that no person no place
and no thing has any power over us
we create all our situations and all our
circumstances by our thinking feeling
patterns
and then we usually give away our power
by blaming others when things do not go
the way we want
is this true for you
we all have things we believe and ideas
about ourselves
I want you to say to yourself your name
I love you I really really love you I
love you I really really love you it's a
new thing you probably haven't done it
before but what we're really trying to
do is to connect with the inner child
within who has been neglected for so
very long most of us when we look in a
mirror we criticize ourselves we make
fun of ourselves we say derogatory
things to ourselves it's a habit and
what we want you to do is to start
connecting with that inner child within
you that wants so much to be loved
and hasn't been for perhaps years and
years and years and years and maybe
never when it was a child
I know this is a tough one to stay but
if it's too tough to start with you can
start with something like
Louise I'm willing to learn to like you
not quite so threatening
so I want you to this is something I
want you to do
a lot first thing in the morning I want
you to get in the habit of having your
little mirror with you whipping it out
at any time or anytime you pass a mirror
say something nice to yourself I I will
look at myself and say you look
fantastic kid and sometimes I'll say you
know you may not be as tight and taut as
you used to be but you're fabulous
you're absolutely wonderful we want to
be our own cheerleader we want the
things that we say to ourselves support
us and love us and make us feel good or
make us feel silly
you know you're a hot potato
and it's not only just saying you love
yourself but do your affirmations into
in front of a mirror do forgiveness in
front of a mirror if you have somebody
you need to forgive do it in front of a
mirror and have get yourself if you have
a big mirror sit down in front of it
because you won't run away you can't
it's too hard to get up and you can sit
there and you can cry but you'll go
through it whatever it is and it'll be
fast
the mirror as small as this may be can
really help you connect with yourself
we're looking in the mirror and saying
how can I make you happy what can I do
to make you happy today every single
thought we have or every sentence we
speak is an affirmation and it's either
positive or negative and it's going out
from us and it's creating our
experiences however when we talk about
doing affirmations what we're talking
about is making definite positive
statements to create something in our
life or to remove something in our life
you see if you stand there and say I
don't want this job or I don't want this
relationship or I don't want these hips
or I don't want whatever that does not
get you what you want that's what I call
fighting the negative and it doesn't do
anything but keep what you have that you
say you don't want however if you start
saying and doing affirmations that I
have a wonderful new new job or I have
this most absolutely marvelous
relationship then you're beginning to
create what it is you do want
affirmations are like planting seeds
and if you think for a moment when you
put a seed in the ground you do not get
instant tomato plant or instant
strawberries or instant oak tree that
seed goes in the ground and it has to
germinate
that's the first thing which means it
breaks open its little shell and little
Roots begin to go down
and it gets nourishment from the Earth
and only then does the first Little
Chute come up through the ground
now when we're doing affirmations too
often people say well that isn't a
million dollars and they stomp on that
first Little Shoot they don't give it a
chance to grow
ing affirmations is like planting a seed
in the ground and watering is it it is
like repeating your affirmations and you
just keep doing them and you keep doing
them and you keep doing them and it
doesn't matter whether you see the
results or you don't see the results and
sometimes it just takes time and too
many people will do affirmations for two
or three days and say see it doesn't
work
you know if
everything happens in the perfect time
space sequence and we want to trust that
and we want to know that so if you begin
to do affirmations for yourself and I
think it's important that we do that on
a daily basis decide what you want
and begin to do positive statements in
present tense for what you want you
never want to say I will have or I'm
going to have because if you do that it
keeps it in the future and remember if
you say I have a wonderful new apartment
and you're living in a dump it doesn't
mean that this is not a true statement
it means you are planting the seed that
will germinate and grow and become the
new apartment so you just keep doing it
no matter what where you are resentment
is a pattern that eats away at the body
and becomes cancer resentment and anger
are very different anger is and you
scream and yell like a baby babies get
angry instantly and they yell and streak
and then they're through and two minutes
later their smiles will just light up a
room because they've gotten it out what
we do
is we take offense
at somebody for having done something
that we created to begin with
because we're all 100 responsible and we
don't do anything about it and we put it
down in here and we start to let it seed
and it boils and it eats away at us and
if we have it long enough we can create
cancer
see diseases like arthritis are created
from things patterns of criticism
arthritic people are always very very
critical people now they may be sweet on
the outside but that means that the
criticism is turned Inward and they're
doing a constant negative put down
number on themselves because you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want 10 more amazing rules from Louise
Hay check out the video right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there now I
know that you've heard me say many times
or you've read or on the listed on the
hopes that loving yourself is the most
powerful thing we can do I think that
everything you think and everything you
speak